bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau 7,8
week-end une émission dédiée aux sorties
et aux loisirs
au sommaire de ce numéro aujourd'hui
nous allons parler de la fête de la
science sur saint quentin en yvelines
plusieurs institutions ouvrent leurs
portes et c'est la première fois que
l'ufr des sciences de la santé simone
veil de l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines et participe un
passionné vis mois présentera ce
week-end au bourget une voiture de
collection
il a lui même créé une simca 5 berline
est le mot au bourget et nous
consacrerons une page aux enfants avec
notamment un ouvrage et des sorties ciné
et sortir et que pour eux le requiem de
mozart est une des pièces maîtresses du
compositeur autrichien pour le découvrir
ou le redécouvrir de kerlouan courtois
viva voce l'interprète ce week-end pour
en parler nous sommes avec christian
coat an bonjour vous êtes le président
de l'association
alors le coeur viva voce le monde le dit
peut-être rien aux téléspectateurs
puisqu'il est tout récent c'est en fait
l'association croque-notes vous savez
tous récemment changé de nom pourquoi ça
croque notes est une chorale qui existe
depuis 32 ans et on estimé que le nom
n'était pas très représentatif des
oeuvres qu'on représentait sur
essentiellement sur saint quentin en
yvelines
donc on a fait une petite enquête
interne et on est arrivé on a changé de
nom vers car viva voce
après différents différents débats voilà
donc c'est le ce sont les premiers
concerts sous ce nom là vous avez
modifié votre répertoire
non le répertoire est le même mais bon
croque notes depuis des années a
interprété des oeuvres comme le messie
de haendel le gloria de vivaldi là cette
année c'est le requiem de mozart
donc on a trouvé que croque notes
correspondait plus très bien à notre
répertoire
on chante sur saint quentin en yvelines
on chante à versailles et montfort
l'amaury donc on est un petit peu
un petit peu sur toute la région et viva
voce on a trouvé que c'était plus adapté
voilà j'espère que vous appréciez si
c'est original
ce requiem vous en parlait il ya
quelques secondes ce qui l'a écrite
l'année de sa mort est-ce qu'elle a des
parties particularité c'est une oeuvre
qui est qui est très connue donc ça fait
évidemment le public a toujours envie d'
on ne s'en lasse pas on a toujours envie
de l'entendre c'est son histoire est un
petit peu complexes vous l'a bien vu
lors du film dans le film amadeus
c'est sa composition est assez assez
intéressante et ce qui cause c'est une
oeuvre qui correspond bien à notre
chorale puisque pour les quatre pupitres
évidemment sont représentées on a des
solistes
il ya un orchestre ça au niveau 2 des
endroits où on va donner le requiem ça
correspond bien à l'emplacement à
l'acoustique
voilà donc c'est il ya des parallèles
entre votre association et les capacités
vocales et le requiem
oui les quatre pupitres sont assez
équitablement représentées dans le champ
donc c'est ce qui est intéressant
et qu'est ce qui plaît particulièrement
dans cette oeuvre le fait c'est une
oeuvre qui est assez extraordinaire
parce que le plus plu on la travaille et
plus on la prie si c'est absolument le
sud 9 hrs absolument remarquable et je
crois ça demande beaucoup de travail
ça fait un an qu un an qu'on est dessus
et on ne s'en lasse pas à travailler on
arrive toujours à découvrir dès des
nouvelles des nouvelles sensations et
c'est ça qui est ça qui nous a poussé
vraiment à aller vers le requiem de
mozart est justement ce week-end vous
saurez une cinquantaine de choristes
avec dix sept musiciens
est-ce que c'est compliqué de travailler
en étant si chaque mardi soir on a une
répétition
les choristes les 50 choristes sont à
ceux viennent viennent très
régulièrement on a c'est absolument
nécessaire pour arriver à ce niveau de
champ et je vous disais 10 et 1 en un an
de travail plus des week-ends de
répétition des cours de la technique
vocale là ont dernièrement on a pu
travailler c'est très récent avec les
musiciens donc leur qu'istres doki à
orchestra est difficile de régler les
15h02 c'est difficile ce qui est
difficile c'est qu'on a toujours des
coupures aussi avec les vacances
scolaires ou bombe par exemple cet été
quand on s'arrête de moi ben ils font
reprendre ses c'est toujours un peu
délicat parce que quand on était à la
plage mais on s'entraîne peut-être pas
trop à chanter le requiem de mozart
mais voilà enfin c'est difficile mais
c'est tellement on est tellement pris
que ça ne s'est pas un effort démesuré
c'est un plaisir de chanter de tout peut
dire tous les choristes qui sont lâchant
2 par plaisir et par l'ansa samedi vous
jouez dans l'église saint-victor de
guyancourt est ce que l'église est un
lieu privilégié pour ce type de musique
c'est évident que toutes ces oeuvres
sacrées doivent être interprétées dans
des églises en priorité on a la chance à
guyancourt d'avoir l'église saint-victor
qui est qui a été refaite qui est
absolument somptueuse et qui a une
acoustique est vraiment extraordinaire
elle correspond bien au niveau de sa
taille 1 à notre coeur jour-là 10 50
personnes les musiciens donc c'est
typiquement l'endroit où on a envie de
chanter le requiem de mozart quand le
prochain
longtemps cherché à lyon on cherche
d'abord l'acoustique où c'est une
question de grandeur de salou
il ya évidemment la grandeur de la salle
les églises vont elles sont plus ou
moins importantes
elles ont une acoustique et plus ou
moins bonnes saint-victor si on prend ne
serait ce qu en course 1 victoire à une
très bonne acoustique le cap saint
jacques
pas du tout le cap st-jacques n'est pas
une église au départ c'est une grange
donc on est et l'association le coeur
viva voce étant basé à guyancourt il est
évident qu'on est avant tout attirés par
l'église de guyancourt et qui a toute
une histoire mais c'est vrai que la
taille de l'endroit on va interpréter
notre concert et l'acoustique ce sont
deux éléments qui sont absolument dieu
merci christian pothin de tous ces
détails je vous le rappelle le coeur
viva voce interprète le requiem de
mozart à l'église saint victor de
guyancourt le samedi 10 octobre une
deuxième représentation est prévue le
dimanche 11 à mener cette fois 7 à
versailles autre sujet ce week-end au
parc des eaux par kt des expositions du
bourget se tiendra le 15e salon
automédon une exposition d'autos et
motos de collection et parmi les
véhicules présentés il y aura une
voiture vie sinoise elle est inspirée
deux bolides d'avant guerre et a été
entièrement créé par collectionneurs à
la salle
sept mille heures de travail 3500 euros
de budget 34 chevaux sous le capot il
lui que vous l'avez jamais vu
cette simulation berlinette le mans est
le fruit de l'imagination d'un la salle
ancien architecte moteur l'entreprise
automobile française aux chevrons j'en
ai fait je dirais les 90% les 10%
restants étant la partie peintures
carrosserie donc s'ils donnent vraiment
l'éclat final à la au véhicule
donc ça je les fais avec l'équipe vite
que je travaillais en concept car c'est
la concrétisation d'un rêve ça c'est
aussi très plaisant ils ont d'arriver à
quelque chose de concret alors que donc
on en arrivait auparavant tombé amoureux
du modèle ah là là ça se lance dans la
conception de son propre véhicule en
2003 jusqu'à 2011 sa berlinette rendent
hommage au cimc accords dits victorieuse
aux 24 heures du mans par rapport à
l'original la voiture a été allongée en
empattement pour installer le moteur en
position centrale avant le toit a été
descendu de 8 cm de façon à gagner de la
place aussi pour la position du moteur
d'où cet aspect disons beaucoup plus bas
beaucoup plus sportif par rapport à une
simca 5 normal pour l'admirer direction
de salon automédon il se tiendra ce
week-end des 10 et 11 octobre par des
expositions du bourget jusqu'à dimanche
c'est la fête de la science depuis
mercredi de nombreux lieux ont ouvert
leurs portes aux scolaires et ce
week-end ce sera le tour du public de
découvrir laboratoire manipulation et
expériences scientifiques
cette année il ya une nouveauté dans le
programme l'ufr des sciences de la santé
simone veil de l'université versailles
saint quentin dévoile ses laboratoires
et ses équipements gilles coca bonjour
bonjour vous êtes directeur de recherche
justement de cette alu fr vous aurez vos
portes pour la première fois pourquoi
pourquoi ya plusieurs raisons à cela
tout d'abord notre implantation nous
sommes au sein de la ville ça c'était
une volonté des deux côtés une volonté
politique et une volonté de notre part
universitaire d'être au contact de des
personnes de nous de nos deux collègues
et donc il nous paraissait extrêmement
légitime de pouvoir montrer à
nos concitoyens aux saint quentinois que
dans ce bâtiment on ne faisait pas
qu'enseigner on faisait aussi de la
recherche de la recherche de très haut
niveau qui je l'espère les intéressent
comme nous intéresse nous et j'espère
qu'on pourra leur faire partager notre
passion et éveiller chez nos jeunes
justement cette flamme qui nous anime et
qu'on voit briller à eux d'ailleurs
puisque c'est maintenant ça fait deux
jours que trois jours que nous les
accueillons public
on a vraiment oui oui de bons retours
donc ça nous ça nous radis et d'ailleurs
du coup ça style encore plus les jeunes
chercheurs les chercheurs plus anciens
comme moi dans cette démarche ses
activités et c'est fantastique de voir
que finalement tout le monde se mobilise
autour de l'événement chez nous quand
même la recherche médicale ça peut
paraître peu accessible vous présenter
quoi au public commençait tout séjour de
toutes ces journées ça c'est une vraie
bonne question ça a été une question
qu'on a qu'on a traîné pendant un petit
moment
vous savez que l'ufr en fait a ouvert
ses portes seulement il ya deux ans et
demi donc c'est on n'est pas vieux sur
le site bâtiments neufs extrêmement
restreint mont-joli et l'an dernier déjà
nous on avait réfléchi à ouvrir nos
portes et on s'est rendu compte que
quand on a commencé à réfléchir vraiment
à l'exercice on n'était pas prêt en fait
et donc on a pris le temps de bien
réfléchir d'essayer d'organiser ça sur
quatre jours ça mobilise beaucoup de
personnes en fait est de savoir ce qu'on
allait présenter en a choisi de mettre
un peu d'histoire dedans et aussi de
montrer la technologie les avancées
technologiques et les avancées de soins
de thérapeutique aussi les approches qui
sont développés au sein des laboratoires
qui seront ici notamment lors de la
visite on peut découvrir
l'histologie est-ce que c'est absolument
rui l'histologie donc c'est une de ceux
de ses de ses plateformes technologiques
que nous avons il y en a au nombre de
six donc je pense qu'on a peut-être au
travers de certains
n mais bon à votre question l'histologie
il faut comprendre que lorsque vous avez
un organe très souvent pour voir son
état sain pathologiques ou et la maladie
où elle se développe
comment caractériser cellule au sein de
ceux de cet organe il faut des approches
tout à fait particulière donc il faut
peut-être découper un peu ce tissu sssa
l'histologie c'est essayer de regarder
au sein du tissu malade ce qui est en
train de se passer de se développer et
pour vos téléspectateurs géré les choses
simples c'est quand on donne et des
grades de maladies très souvent très
souvent c'est basé justement sur des
critères d'histologie où on voit en
fonction de l'état pathologique des
cellules dans cet état malade qui fait
plus ou moins avancés on peut le frappe
directement sur ces couples à et lors de
la visite c'est aussi des laboratoires
qui sont ouverts nous avons pu en voir à
vous nous avons découvert des bactéries
des parasites ce qui peut beaucoup
surprend et vous cherchez vous ont dit
que c'était un laboratoire classique et
je vous propose de regarder un sujet
préparé avec camille lambert biologie
cellulaire biologie moléculaire ça peut
paraître un peu barbare mais dans ce
laboratoire on étudie des éléments que
vous avez sans doute déjà croisé des
bactéries comme l'aï coli responsable
d'intoxications alimentaires ou le
staphylocoque doré infections
hospitalières mais aussi quelques
parasites et là vous avez des verts qui
impressionne toujours
les visiteurs puisque c'est fait c'est
les fameux thénia qui se développe au
sein de l'organisme
lorsqu'on a infecté par ce genre de
verre généralement l'infection au tennis
survient après une alimentation avec de
la viande qui n'a pas été suffisamment
bien cuites par exemple est contaminée
préalable par les eaux de ce type de
micro organismes dans cette pièce on
prépare notamment des cellules certaines
humaine
pour étudier l'expression d'un gène pour
identifier l'évolution d'une maladie ou
d'une thérapie ce laboratoire fait
partie est un laboratoire vraiment
classique que l'on retrouve en termes
d'organisation un peu partout dans le
monde
c'est le laboratoire est essentielle
dans le cadre des études en biologie
laboratoires de niveau l1 comment la
peine où on pratique les expériences
soit à l'échelle de la molécule adn
protéines soient les seuls salaires sur
cette manipulation le chercheur a
préparé des cellules issues d'une femme
décédée en 1950
ces cellules sont ensuite placés dans un
incubateur pour qu'elles continuent de
se multiplier alors j'écris aux calendes
sujet on a pu voir une manipulation jeu
nous a été faite un peu spécialement
pour nous mais est-ce que des
expériences vont pouvoir être visible
alors visibles oui mais pas trop pour
cette année on a vraiment justement
établi le programme en quarante deux ans
de temps la première notre première
ouverture la rencontre avec le public
avec les beaucoup d'étudiants donc de
collèges et de lycées de l'agglomération
et ça c'est vraiment extrêmement
enrichissant j'espère repos pour tout le
monde pour nous ça l'est apparemment ça
l'est aussi pour pour ces jeunes ces
jeunes étudiants et dès l'année
prochaine donc nous sommes en train de
mettre en place aujourd'hui des
expériences que ces étudiants et le
grand public d'ailleurs qui doit venir
samedi on a beaucoup de réservations
déjà pour pourra faire
merci j'ai clos kia pour votre venue en
plateau si vous souhaitez découvrir la
recherche alu fr c'est samedi 10 octobre
alors lors de cette fête de la science
d'autres lieux sont à découvrir comme
l'aube vers l'observatoire versailles
saint quentin un lieu habituellement
fermé au public
annabelle doazit responsable
communication de l'observatoire était
l'invité de 7,8 journal jeudi soir
cette année on a une grande nouveauté
qui est l'accès au mur d'image immersif
qui ouvre là cette année pour le grand
public donc c'est un million
d'ordinateurs avec un écran géant qui
marchent en 3d avec un système de
tracking donc avec des lunettes 3
des puits des petites des petits
capteurs sur les lunettes on peut être
complètement immergé dans une simulation
ça permet de chercheurs de faire un
travail collaboratif et interactif et on
fait des ateliers pour les petits et les
grands donc voilà tout le monde est très
content alors pour découvrir le
programme plus complet de l'observatoire
vous pouvez retrouvez l'entretien en
totalité sur notre site internet
pour conclure cette page fête de la
science il ya un dernier rendez vous à
ne pas manquer c'est le village des
sciences qui se tiendra dimanche à magny
les hameaux de 14h à 18h vous pourrez
découvrir le light painting c'est l'art
de peindre avec de la lumière ou un
espace entièrement dédié aux qu'il m'a
un peu plus d'un mois de la coff 21 la
conférence des nations unies sur les
changements climatiques qui est
organisée à paris on passe maintenant à
une sélection d'activités pour les plus
jeunes d'entre nous c'est notre rendez
vous hebdomadaire vous en avez pris
l'habitude cette semaine les libraires
du pavé du canal s'intéresse à un public
particulier les enfants et leur choix
s'est porté sur la petite soeur du
chaperon rouge donc la petite soeur du
chaperon rouge de didier l'évier de
clotilde perrin aux éditions milan donc
on connaît tous le petit chaperon rouge
la grand-mère le loup mais ce qu'on ne
sait pas c'est que le petit chaperon
rouge a une petite soeur qui s'appelle
carlotta alors carlotta la célébrité les
paillettes la jet set ça n'intéresse pas
du tout le petit chaperon rouge passe sa
vie à signer des autographes
la grand mère elle se faire faire des
des soins et des massages dans des spas
elle ce qu'elle aime c'est se promener
dans la forêt découvrir tous les animaux
de la forêt et un jour elle va
rencontrer le loup qui n'est plus du
tout le grand méchant nous il a vieilli
la plus dedans ils mangent que de la
bouillie et vont devenir très amis et se
loue va lui faire découvrir toute la
population de la forêt tous les animaux
des contes de fées et un jour carlotta
surprend une conversation entre le petit
chaperon rouge et sa grand mère elles
veulent faire un immense parc
d'attraction dans la forêt ce qui va
détruire le
lieu d'habitation de tous et de tous ses
nouveaux amis donc elle décide de
déménager la fois c'est un très beau
conte écologique qui permet également de
découvrir tous les personnages des
contes de fées on peut les identifier
puisque le dessin est vraiment très
clair on découvre même charles perrault
qui selon l'auteur vit là depuis
toujours et écrit quelque chose sur la
forêt des skis des qui se passe un
événement
voilà c'est assez drôle c'est assez
touchant aussi parce que carlotta là
qu'une envie c'est de se préserver son
environnement mais elle a aucune
rancoeur envers le petit chaperon rouge
et sa grand mère voilà un bel album pour
les enfants à partir de 5 ans visiter
les monuments nationaux de manière
ludique c'est le principe de monument
jeu d'enfant
des visites et des ateliers sont au
programme et bien sûr les monuments
présent dans les yvelines sont à
découvrir un sujet de sephora man amani
et patrick jacques de dixmude pour la
17e édition de monument jeu d'enfant le
centre des monuments nationaux proposent
des activités destinées spécialement aux
jeunes publics les 10 et 11 octobre
prochains
partout en france et notamment dans les
yvelines une façon de sensibiliser les
familles au patrimoine architectural en
le rendant accessible
l'idée c'est de donner envie aux enfants
et à leur famille d'investir notre
monument et les monuments général par un
biais qui peut être ludique ou
merveilleux qui va peut-être être plus
attirant que une visite conférence
les enfants de 5 à 12 ans sont invités à
remonter le temps au travers d'ateliers
divers et variés suivant les lieux danse
maquillage costumes peinture pendant ce
temps les accompagnateurs bénéficient de
tarifs réduits pour visiter les
monuments
j'aime beaucoup faire ça parce que ça me
rappelle l'époque d'avant comment ils
s'habillaient la mode et c'est assez
drôle que nous les avons pas des talons
alors que nous jouerons pour te
fatalement quand il faut sur pattes et
c'est les filles voire des talons cette
année pour hommes du mans jeu d'enfant
nous avons décidé de demander à une
chorégraphe de chercher ce qui
l'intéressait particulièrement en tant
que danseuse contemporaine et elle nous
a proposé de faire découvrir le le
bâtiment déjà dans un dans une sorte
première petite promenade marché et de
créer avec les enfants des danses ce
week end
des ateliers danse vous attendent à la
villa savoye de poissy et au château de
maison à maison laffitte et un atelier
laiterie bergerie au domaine nationale
de rambouillet c'est une association qui
fête cette année ses 40 ans elle est
basée à plaisir et rassemble aujourd'hui
400 adhérents passionnés par la culture
l'histoire et la lecture
cette association ses lectures et
dialogues daya bay belle bonjour vous
êtes responsable des conférences de
l'association mais tout d'abord est ce
que vous pouvez me parler de lecture et
dialogues bien sûr lecture et dialogue
donc a été créé en 1975 elle et c'est
une association très active puisque nous
avons beaucoup d'activités qui sont
proposés à nos adhérents et non
adhérents
nous avons des groupes discussions c'est
à dire des groupes de lecture ou des
contes cinéma qui permettent de
d'échanger sur un lit un film livre nous
à nous organisons bien sûr des
conférences des rencontres avec des
auteurs souvent connus ddd
des frontières d exposition commentée
dans paris hors de paris des promenades
culturelles enfin 7,13 très ouvert très
excessive dans le nom de l'association
et la lecture il y a trente groupes de
lecture il les groupes de lecture ce
sont des groupes d'une douzaine de
personnes qui se réunissent
régulièrement une disons une fois par
mois et qui échangent des commentaires
sur le livre qu'elles ont lu et c'est
très enrichissant parce que
effectivement les points de vue sont
très différents et ça apporte énormément
et justement un groupe de lecture ça se
fondent comment par intérêt littéraire
par jean les terreurs pardon ou par
affinité entre les adhérents pas du tout
ce sont des groupes qui se forment bon
impôt par des adhérents c'est il ya
toujours une animatrice de groupes qui
pilotent son groupe
les livres sont choisis en commun en
début d'année il ya plusieurs livres qui
sont choisis et les les groupes se
réunissent ça il ya une parte de
convivialité puisque les gens se
reçoivent mutuellement
il ya sept ouverts à tous sont ouverts à
tous absolument vous le disais tout à
l'heure ça dépasse le cadre de la
lecture quand même parce que vous
proposez aussi des visites commentées de
paris et sa région
voilà le lien de tout ça c'est quoi
c'est la culture c'est la culture c'est
l'ouverture sur le sur le monde sur le
voilà et dans le cadre de vos activités
vous disiez il ya aussi des rencontres
avec des auteurs
quelqu'un mardi prochain le 13 octobre
exactement qu'est ce que vous proposez
de rencontre avec marie hélène lafon qui
est écrivain qui est marié à marie
hélène lafon est un prof est
actuellement professeur mais elle mène
aussi parallèlement sous le travail de
cette écrivaine elle est
elle est agrégée de lettres de grammaire
et elle est professeur de français latin
et grec à paris est là elle s'est mise à
l'écriture à l'âge de 104 ans ce n'est
pas très jeune et depuis elle n'a pas
cessé d'écrire bien sûr elle a publié de
nombreux romans elle a commencé par des
nouvelles des nouvelles qui n'ont pas
été publiés tout de suite et qu'elle a
publiés par la suite elle a obtenu des
quelques prix littéraires notamment pour
le soir du chien pour lequel elle a
obtenu le prix renaudot des lycéens
elle a obtenu le prix marguerite du faux
pour des nouvelles notamment des purges
et elle a écrit beaucoup de livres
notamment et qu'ils quittent tous
étaient plus ou moins pris mais le prix
le les pays qui est un petit peu
autobiographique l'annoncent joseph qui
a eu un énorme succès qu'elle a pu
paraître en 2014 là elle vient de sortir
un livre qui s'appelle chantier et qui
fait partie de la rentrée littéraire
d'ailleurs donc nous sommes tous très
impatients de la recevoir elle s'inspire
aussi beaucoup du monde rural de l 25
étudiants vote l est elle même le dit
elle se plaît à dire qu'elle a est né
dans une famille de paysans et
effectivement elle est née dans le
cantal et beaucoup de ses livres se sont
dans ce milieu là se passe dans ce
milieu là elle a une écriture assez
précises ciselés et elle met en scène
des personnages vraiment attachant par
leur part leur lucidité qu'ils ont en
eux et l'or l'or
les prix sont très terrien ses
personnages alors pour participer à la
rencontre d'un point de vue organisation
il faut s'inscrire commence alors on a
pas d'inscription préalable il faut se
présenter un quart d'heure avant la
représentation a lieu à 20h
20h45 à la clé des champs dans l'espace
coluche un plaisir à côté du théâtre les
de coluche plaisir d'inverser daniel
weibel pour toutes ces explications
l'automne est sans doute l'une des
périodes les plus riches en couleurs à
cette occasion l'union régionale
photographique s'associe à tv fil 78
pour proposer un concours que vous soyez
amateurs ou passionnés n'hésitez pas à
nous envoyer vos meilleurs clichés
un jeune un jury désignera le lauréat et
il sera reçu ici même en plateau pour
nous parler de son travail voilà le 7-8
week-end est terminée je rouvre vous
remercier de nous avoir suivis et je
vous je vous souhaite un excellent
week-end à la semaine prochaine